hi guys sci-fi recapped here before we
start morning spoilers ahead today I'm
going to explain an American superhero
crime and drama movie called Hancock
starring Will Smith the film tells the
story of a man named John Hancock he is
an alcoholic who possesses superpowers
including flight invulnerability and
superhuman strength but unlike
superheroes in general he is not a
superhero loved by the people of Los
Angeles almost everyone hates him both
good and bad people he also becomes
enraged when referred to as an [ __ ]
by the locals at the beginning of the
movie Hancock falls asleep on a public
bench by the side of the road not long
after there is a boy who suddenly wakes
him up the boy hopes that he can wake up
soon and stops the criminals who are in
action which is reported on the
television knowing this he immediately
reacts by capturing the mafia group who
is running away in a car these mafia
members have weapons but that is not a
problem for him who has superpowers
however he is scolded by the police and
local residents for his Reckless nature
when he tackles a problem he makes an
even worse mess in overcoming these
three criminals Hancock and his heroic
action makes a big loss because he also
destroys police cars in public
facilities in other words the losses he
incurred are greater than the losses
incurred by the criminals
meanwhile there is a man named Ray Embry
he works as a public relations
specialist in a private company he
offers a business concept to the board
of directors but sadly the concept is
not approved by them on his way home he
gets stuck in traffic right on the train
tracks where a train is about to pass
frantically he cannot go anywhere
because the car in front and behind him
cannot move either then he decides to
get out of the car but unfortunately his
clothes get stuck in it just at the
right time Hancock appears and
irrationally derails the car to save Ray
as a result Rey's car crashes into
someone else's car in an overturned
condition then he instead crashes
himself into the train to stop it making
the environment around there become
chaotic as usual the citizens
immediately criticize him except for Ray
who is very thankful to him for saving
him just now with his flying ability Rey
is escorted by Hancock to his house
arriving there Rey is greeted by his
wife Marion also his son Aaron from now
it can be seen that Mary is one of the
people who does not like Hancock as a
superhero even she has refused him to
eat together at her house on the other
hand Aaron is a fan of him
from all the Los Angeles residents Rey
is the only one who believes that
Hancock has a good side in him that way
he can turn into a superhero that people
love by improving his Public Image to
make it happen Rey encourages him to
admit all the mistakes he has made so
far such as destroying public facilities
to other things that harm the citizens
in his actions Rey also tells him to
Grant the wishes of the residents all
this time namely the residents want him
to be imprisoned for all the losses he
has made until Los Angeles needs him
properly at first he is reluctant but in
the end he agrees with Rey
when he arrives at the prison he meets
another inmate however they stare at him
in disgust and immediately block his way
when he wants to pass turns out most of
them are the people who went to jail
because of Hancock so they seem to be
really annoyed with him after that he
politely asks them not to get in his way
but they still don't eat his words
because he is so upset he ends up
assaulting the two of them thus the
other inmates avoid him out of fear and
quickly leave him alone later Hancock is
visited by Ray who knows about the mess
that he caused earlier encouraging him
to be patient he is also visited by Mary
and Aaron who bring him homemade
spaghetti
since Hancock was in prison Los
Angeles's crime rate Rises the climax is
when there is a bank robbery where the
criminals carry a lot of weapons and
explosives therefore Hancock is
eventually released to help the police
he also gets his superhero costume for
the first time after being taught
manners by Rey he then foils the robbery
orchestrated by Red Parker with Hancock
slicing off his hand to prevent him from
activating a detonation switch because
of this he is praised as a superhero for
the first time by the locals afterwards
Hancock has dinner with Ray and Mary he
asks them how they come to meet each
other in essence Mary turns out to be
Rey's second wife while Aaron is the son
of his first wife who had died in
childbirth when it is Hancock's turn to
tell his story it is revealed that he is
amnesiac and an immortal that moment
when he woke up in Miami Hospital he had
no idea who he really was the only thing
he knew was that there was a chewing gum
and two movie tickets in his pocket but
he couldn't remember anything about it
strangely enough it happened 80 years
ago in the meantime Mary looks at him
with pity it seems that she is familiar
with his story causing her to cry
after they finished dinner a drunk Ray
is carried by Hancock to his house
before Hancock wants to go home he meets
with Mary in the kitchen he then kisses
her only for her to toss him outside
destroying the walls of her house it
turns out that she has superpowers like
him too looks like they are the same
species Hancock is very surprised not to
think that Mary has the same superpowers
as him
the next morning Ray who is woken up
from his sleep is very surprised to see
that his house was so messy Mary then
explains to him that it was Hancock's
doing because he sneezed last night
causing the wall to shatter after a
while Hancock comes to Mary's house
again he then does some tests on Mary
because he is still curious about what
happened last night when he presses the
fork against her shoulder the fork bends
instead and also when he hits her head
with a rolling pin Mary feels fine about
it because of it he has many questions
for her and tells her to come to his
residence
arriving there she talks with Hancock in
private she claims that actually she is
his little sister and then they have
lived for three thousand years she also
explains that they are the last
descendants of their species on the
other hand Hancock disbelieves her about
the last claim thinking that the whole
thing was [ __ ] furthermore he
immediately leaves and flies away to
inform Rey about her superpower Mary who
does not want Rey to know about it
chases after him the two of them inside
a violent battle across the city until
Ray quietly Witnesses the fight from a
building
after the fight he returns home at the
same time Hancock and Mary also arrives
there at that time Rey is very surprised
why Mary can fly and has superpowers
Mary then explains the truth
she admits that Hancock is actually her
husband from the past but that she chose
to quietly leave him once he had lost
his memories about them knowing this
fact Hancock feels sad and disappointed
with Mary as well as Ray who is also
annoyed by her statement
one night Hancock stops a liquor store
robbery unfortunately the criminals are
able to shoot him in the body causing
him to be hospitalized after a while
Mary approaches him and continues her
explanation that their species has a
weakness that is if they are close or
have feelings for each other then the
superpowers possessed by them will
slowly disappear for a moment becoming
Mortals she also tells him that the last
time they were together was 80 years
before at that moment Hancock was
attacked right in his head by the
criminals to save Mary consequently he
had Amnesia and only had one chewing gum
and two movie tickets in his pocket
meanwhile Parker whose hand has been
sliced off earlier manages to escape
from the prison with several other
criminals he decides to attack Hancock
in the hospital for Revenge unluckily
Mary is caught in the crossfire when she
tries to protect Hancock causing her to
be injured after that an angry Hancock
immediately recovers and immediately
kills the criminals while the doctors
are trying to save Mary's life but in
the process Hancock gets shot in his
body again by Parker just in the right
time he is saved by Ray who cuts off
Parker's other hand with a fire ax
before killing him as well sometime
after that he finally realizes what to
do next he immediately throws himself
out of the hospital trying to increase
his distance from Mary so that she can
recover quickly he eventually flies
towards the Moon
a month later Rey and his family
suddenly receive a call from Hancock who
is now in New York he reveals that he
has imprinted the moon's surface with
Rey's all heart marketing logo which was
previously rejected by his directors the
movie ends happily even though Rey
already knew all the facts about Hancock
and Mary in the end they remain good
friends and Mary remains Rey's wife in a
mid credit scene Hancock confronts a
criminal holding a woman at gunpoint the
criminal demands Hancock to help him
escape from the police while calling him
an [ __ ] in the process which
infuriates Hancock
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching